le village de percer ce fait beau on
atteindra les nombreux visiteurs qui
arriveront de peu partout au québec des
longs séjours de jacky arrive les gens
qui louent pour une semaine des unités
avec cuisinette là des gens qui ont hâte
de sortir de la ville
800 me remet le propriétaire de
l'auberge ou pic de l'horreur accueille
ses premiers clients cette fin de
semaine une nouvelle tendance semble se
profiler les touristes québécois réserve
pour de plus longs séjours dernier
journée de août puis septembre et encore
de la place avec la gaspésie c'est pas
complet en gaspésie partout mais les
semaines où tout le monde veulent
voyager en même temps l'as est ce si sûr
que ça fait longtemps que c'est plein
dans la cuisine d'un nouveau restaurant
qui ouvrira le 11 juin le jeune chef
danny kass et déjà aux fourneaux avec
est-ce qu'on a un talent peu partout
j'espère de voir un peu le québec le qui
viennent ici l'on pense qu'on va avoir
une saison également sinon plus forte
que l'an passé puisque y est ce qui est
plaisant cette année c'est qu'ils ont
aussi un peu plus à quoi s'attendre
contrairement à l'an passé où c'était un
vide total puis apparaît date on savait
même pas si on allait avoir une saison
l'an passé donc le centre ça nous permet
finalement de mieux se préparer
julienc l'outil est propriétaire d'une
flotte de cinq bateaux qui transportent
les touristes à l'île bonaventure
cette année il ne prend pas de
réservation il ya trop de monde dit il
premier arrivé premier servi comme dans
le bon vieux temps holloway les gens à
perdre rappelle à toutes les fois chez
nous mais là je transfère mes appels de
mes billets très méchante heures à tous
des soins et des abris
alors j'ai l'impression ça va être super
bon
j'allais oublier les fous de bassan sont
arrivés le singulier volatiles attire
beaucoup de monde en 2019
65000 personnes ont foulé l'île
bonaventure selon la sépaq plus de 500
milles en gaspésie une très grosse 16
ans du 1021 risque d'être l'année de
tous les records
ici bruno lelièvre radio-canada à percer